let's say I finished my first draft what
am i doing who am i showing it to what
am i thinking well the very first thing
you should do when you finish a first
draft is go out and celebrate truly
there are so many people that start a
draft and never finish
and you've just by just finishing a
draft you've probably put yourself in
the top 10% of all screenwriters just by
doing that one thing and seeing
something to completion seeing a first
draft come to life that's a really huge
accomplishment especially for a
first-time writer so we really encourage
people to take note of that to celebrate
and then I would say after that take
take a little break from from writing so
that you can be fresh so that you can
come back to it with new eyes now a
first draft is just the very very very
beginning of a very long journey towards
being produced or towards being a
professional screenwriter and so after
you've had a chance to take a break it's
really important to go back to that
draft and look at it through the eyes of
an editor to really look at it
objectively so that you can rewrite it
and we in our book we have a whole
chapter on rewriting and things that you
can do to get your script ready when
it's ready to be seen by eyes other than
your own we generally recommend that
this is where you would send it to your
writers group this is where you would
get professional feedback where you
really need mentorship where you really
need somebody who can guide you through
the rewrite process and once that's
happened once you really have a working
draft that you can send out then you
that's when you start contacting
producers that's when you can start
sending it out to festivals and to
contests and things like that generally
speaking we find that people have more
success trying to work with producers
independent producers and teaming up
with people in that way as opposed to
trying to get an agent or manager right
out
right out of the gate it's pretty rare
that that scenario happens with a
first-time writer so you know work with
work with the connections that you have
make sure that your networking make sure
that you're sending it to the people
that you know and if it really is truly
ready to send out to the world you
should be getting back some some pretty
positive responses at that time I would
say also that the the thing about a
first project is that it's not them
you're not writing it for it to be made
you're writing it to be your calling
card so every writer needs to have a
couple of scripts that they can show as
this is an example of what I can do I
know my craft I know the business of
this art form I can marshal people's
emotions I can take a character on a
journey so because nobody's gonna buy
your first script or your set first two
scripts you're looking to get work
you're looking for people to say wow you
know what you're doing I have this
little project and weird we need a
writer for it so that that the that
that's why you don't want that first
project to be your weird kind of you
know highly stylized fashion thing
because nobody wants to make that you
know they're looking to see can you do a
good basic job of your craft I we need a
writer who can do deliver you strong and
tone and genre and gonna really deliver
strong characters and a plot that moves
so a lot of people have the wrong sample
script they have the wrong idea of it
and then they're just constantly holding
out hope that you know somebody's gonna
buy this script and they miss the effect
that no that's not what it's for
for somebody starting out you're trying
to get work and you need to show that
you know your business you know your
your field so that we know we stress
that with writers all the time the truth
is your first script probably nobody
should ever see your second script very
rarely should anybody see but when you
start okay now you're in your third
project your fourth project and now you
really you know you're you're getting
stuff that should be seen but but again
know what you're doing with it you know
this this is a sample of your best work
it's a sample of what you can do
and so that again you know two different
projects one is more your particular
voice the other one really choses as
Vicki said you know you understand John
rrah
you understand the the basic structure
of storytelling because that's this
mysterious thing to producers and
directors and actors and they don't know
where that comes from and they need
writers who can do that and so you've
got to be able to show I'm one of those
people who can do that so the main the
main point of creating this thing is to
be your sample and and what's also
extremely important if this is your
first script and you've gotten it to a
place where it is ready to show people
typically the best thing you can do at
that point is to set it aside and write
something else and write your second
script and get that to a place where you
can show people because then you have
two things that you can show because you
know this this business is funny that
way they if they see something that you
that they like that is maybe not for
them they're gonna say wow I like this
right or what else do they have and if
you don't have anything else then that
says that you're not ready yet to be a
professional so you really need to have
some things under your belt and oh by
the way your first project probably
shouldn't be a feature your first
project should probably be a short film
or you know an internet you know web
series that are too you know five
two-minute episodes you know or you know
something that kind of moves you into
the feature realm the feature
storytelling is the hardest kind of
visual storytelling to do so why would
you start with that you know start start
you know you got a walk before you can
run but you'll have more confidence as
you do these little projects and then
you work your way up saying now I'm
ready to write a feature it's amazing
how many people you know start writing
an epic you know scorns of the rain you
know 100 million dollar big-budget thing
as their first project and it's like
you're just not ready to do that again
go back to the metaphor of the architect
you don't design a skyscraper as your
first thing and your first project needs
to be small in scope so that you can
kind of get better
you